next week Netflix is premiering brand
new episodes of Gilmore Girls it's
coming back yeah me too I love that show
I don't even seem like the kind of guy
who'd be into Gilmore Girls but I just
can't wait okay why are you saying ha
tis I who just said ha it will be me who
says ha again in three two ah sir why
why are you saying ha because the girls
of Gilmore are no match for my favorite
show which premieres its glorious
seventh season this very week
okay now based on your outfit I think we
know what you're what show you're
talking about but it's not back this
week it's a show where gallant men and
women fight for the honor of their
families in a dangerous realm of fire
and sex yeah okay I know but the seventh
season isn't until next summer
Shh do you hear the groaning of the ice
Conan the howling of the blizzard
something is coming and it starts with a
w yes we know winter is coming
winter may I am speaking of wool burgers
wall burgers wait wait the reality show
about Mark Wahlberg's family running a
burger joint in Boston that show yes the
very same of all the shows that grace
the tube we call boob none can match the
epic beefiness of this saga in which the
family of a movie star argues are not
round meat okay I really don't see how
the show could be any good I don't it's
not any good it's every great okay that
made no sense it made yes sense I know
what will convince you
let's read a real scene from Wahlberg
that's a I'll have my intern Brad bring
you a script O'Brien
no I don't want you Brett oh for God's
sake no okay all right all right what a
realistic eagle what this is a script
this is a script for something called
two broke Eagles damn it's Brad
I'm sorry cone and it looks like Brad is
trying to pitch you one of his sitcom
ideas Brad there's a time and a place
take your script back now you hear go
okay good
he took it I saw he took it Thank You
Brad Conan I'll have my other intern Amy
bring you the correct now not if amy is
another Eagle now she definitely is this
is stupid this is just a script called
the big beak theory I told you Amy we
need to set up a general meeting for
that sort of stuff first
Brad Amy both of you get back here and
apologize
no they don't need to apology
what's happening what are they doing Oh
what are they doing oh don't move Conan
it looks like they're mating they're
mating yes I could always sense the
sexual tension between those two just
remain still until they're finished okay
well how long will they be there I'm not
too long
Eagles are Swift and merciless lovers
Conan looks like they're almost done
okay yeah wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute what's on my head right
now oh that's an egg it looks like your
hair is now their nest Conan I can't do
the show with an egg on my head oh
you're going to do 20 shows with that
egg on your head
it takes an eagle egg five weeks to
hatch and your hair is now a protected
habitat by the US Fish and Wildlife
Service you know I'll be honest I
thought this might happen
you thought this might happen yes anyway
did I convince you that wahlburger this
is a great show no all you did was waste
my time I respectfully disagree okay now
I'm sure if you're a fan of Game of
Thrones why you dressed like that
oh this this is how I dress for sex
parties
Tina sex party
[Applause]
you